en
[Musique]
français sur dix testé positif depuis le
premier janvier et les contaminations
reste autre regard des 4 128 mille
nouveaux cas mikron continue à gagner du
terrain et nous ne sommes pas encore au
pic dans ce moment on doit servir les
enfants de france pour traverser cette
crise comme il convient et donc si vous
êtes là et donc je suis là et puis tant
pis si je prends des coups c'est après
tout aussi mon rôle d'en prendre des
révélations qui ont été faites dans dans
ce livre sont absolument révoltante que
vous avez le ventre noué en lisant des
choses pareilles et que si ces faits
sont avérés ils devront évidemment être
sanctionnée avec la plus grande sévérité
il dit avoir vécu des toilettes
chronométrés les cadences infernales
mais aussi la nourriture qu'on distribue
avec parcimonie à des résidents pourtant
fragile
pèsent les assiettes pour qu ils pas
trop de choses vous faut que tu
respectes chasseurs travaux il ya des
personnes qui sont laissés inchangés de
la journée c'est là c'est dans leur
urine dans leur syndicat mais ce n'est
que du chiffre c'est des numéros rien
mais ces 24 heures après l'injection que
la sombre et vivait et remplacé par un
bel alignement je convoque la direction
d'orpea pour des explications et avec
olivier ferrand on se réserve la
possibilité d'une enquête indépendante
de l'igas sur ces faits graves dénoncées
sont avérés je pense que l'ensemble des
parlementaires devraient pouvoir comme
ils le font en prison allez sans
prévenir elle effectué des visites
surprises dans l'intégralité des ehpad
de notre pays quand vous arrivez à
l'improviste ça montre que on est là
pour pouvoir avoir un oeil sur tout ce
qui est question de liberté est question
de soins question de vie et dans des
lieux qui sont quand même plus fermé
c'est pas la jungle mais c'est
effectivement je pense un domaine dans
lequel le capitalisme le plus dur c'est
trouver un eldorado et on peut pas dire
que les personnes âgées soient faites
pour nourrir les eldorados
pour quatre ans durant au gouvernement
hollande aux côtés de phase ii macro
belle connerie gouvernement qu'à une
mener une politique des plus antisociale
toutes ces lois qui ont trahi la gauche
l'action de walsky a eu des propos
racistes la gauche est à côté de la
plaque aujourd'hui par cellule par
manque de propositions manquent de
clarté manque de combat par rapport à
des références sur lesquelles au
contraire les jeunes pourraient pourrait
se retrouver oui je suis resté quatre
ans dans ce gouvernement je suis fier
des combats que j'ai menés
je ne les ai pas tous gagnés je suis
parti sur un désaccord politique soit
parti pas de caprice rené robert était
un photographe de renom à 84 ans il est
mort la semaine dernière en plein coeur
de paris sur ce trottoir sous le regard
indifférent des passants match terrible
qui nous vient du large de la floride
aux états unis voyez un homme seul au
milieu de la mer sur une coque de bateau
il dit faire partie de l'embarcation qui
est venue des bahamas et qui a chaviré
trente neuf personnes sont portées
disparues mardi dernier vers 21h le
photographe fait un malaise en pleine
rue s'écroule devant cette porte
inconscient
les secours ne sont alertés que le
lendemain matin par un sdf il est trop
tard pour sauver l'octogénaire en état
d'hypothermie le crépuscule livre
parfois quelques surprises
détends d'inhabituel roses et violettes
spectacle envoûtant du ciel sur cette
photo non retouchée prise hier sur l'île
de la réunion je dois annuler l'ensemble
de mes concerts suite à un problème de
santé en effet on vient de me dire
gnostique et une tumeur au poumon
tumeurs cancéreuses en cause des nuages
de soufre de cendres et de gaz qui
atténue le rayonnement solaire
l'explication se trouve à plus de 12000
kilomètres de là